[Music]
hi everyone how's it going hope you're
having a good quarantine week which week
is it three four well it depends on
which country you're in actually so
today we did a poll that seats about 350
people participated thank you and we did
I was going to I wanted your input on
what to do so I asked Ben Simon to do
this poll about do you guys want more
puzzles or you want to focus on some
strategies specifically on nimzo-indian
with the doubled pawns and name is and
Dan won by little it was like a last
time I checked it was about like 54% to
46% so thank you for participating very
lovely and so because it was very close
I decided to include some puzzles in our
to our lesson today too so here's the
first puzzle
let's think about it a little and it's
White's to move basically the question
is who do you think will win and how can
you actually achieve that if you think
white will win how can you achieve that
so yeah I'm going to be monitoring the
chat closely and so just feel free to
type in and I'll be the [ __ ] got over
it
hmm
I already have few suggestions all right
so you guys are thinking about 37 a lot
and root d8 I have gotten one from
aquage
nice okay so next and things is a draw
heart I really like it you guys are
already thinking differently about the
position proud of you
so yeah I'll give it another minute or
two and then we can go ahead and see the
answer so one thing that you can think
about is well this one this is a very
strong pot correct so how can you
actually support this that's something
that you can work on
okay so memento mori' you are correct
York t8 is the best move and the idea is
well first of all if you create you take
it if you take it g7 and you can't stop
this pawn because this rook is very
misplaced can't really this is gonna be
a queen and our other idea that we've
talked about so if the king was still on
e7 King G king f7 was possible but in
this situation it's impossible to do
that and you get the Queen and if King
f6 for example now we do the rook d7 s
that was suggested but in earlier in the
chat yeah and now this is another great
supporter and also recap seven mates
coming up
so yeah the position is pretty pretty
amazing for whites alright let's do the
next one so this one is black to move
basically how can you continue with
white and use your how can you continue
with black and use wise mistake great
thank you
so I have suggestions on rook t1 so far
but routing one is interesting but you
have something better
similar idea who are the players this
was a game played in the year 2000 and
they were they weren't really high rated
that we'd ever higher rated but not
Grandmaster high like high rated the
first one is 2 to 3:30 and the black one
is to 407 the ratings I can the writes
down the players oh yeah
so far we have to correct responses so
yeah okay two is the winning move the
idea is after rookie to black is pretty
tied up sorry white is pretty tied up
and why it can't really stop it if you
take this is coming up and bye-bye if
you don't take what are you going to do
are you going to move the stroke
somewhere then you lose the this fish up
and it's already very unpleasant or
let's do one more before they get into
the name is a Indian okay so here all
the white pieces are active how can you
use it
it's actually pretty quite pretty so
yeah a lot of you guys are saying this
good job so this is ideally you want to
get this queenie six right so but you
can't because the Queen on d7 is
protecting the square so you go attack
it and after trying to block you get the
check and King f8 now can someone just
give me the finishing line
Oh Nixon don't worry these are just for
fun to warm people up
you guys want a puzzles so so if this
puzzles are hard for anyone the one
thing that you can do is you can try to
[Music]
think about candidate moves and if the
move that is correct is one of your
candidate moves that's at least very
very nice and I'll be very proud of you
so the try to think about like a mating
net cuz that king is really really kind
of stuck right so preferably gave me a
full line arts give me it's not that
hard give me a full line okay so I'm
getting my age five and then Knight f6
and but if who's the first to give me
checkmate yep all right great any
questions cuz I'm gonna switch to NIMS
Oh Thank You Josh for your deep comments
all right where is my name's ooh
all right here all right guys
okay so I have a bunch of games prefers
to show you and so first one I'm going
to show you is a game that I played and
so I was black and this was in Abu Dhabi
tournaments I would have a Masters 2014
Wow my rating was low and actually this
does the teenager that I played with
Danny on path he was he's right now I
think almost 2500 last time I checked
and yeah so I'm pretty proud of them
dating him
so yeah let's maybe let's start taking a
look at that okay so first of all who
here actually does play this names of
Indian with white or black because the
pawn structure is that I'm talking about
art when you with whites you get these
double pawn and I want to show you how
to play against as black against this
pawn structure and also what are the
main ideas that white can try to pull
off so my opponent in the game put a
tree but there are many other lines that
can lead to this there the f3 lines I
can lead to like f3 a three lines that
can lead to this um double pawn or with
III so I'm gonna try and cover all of
those in our time here oh and while you
guys are still giving me votes on who
plays this with white or black
the link in the description below we do
have another detailed nimzo-indian that
we looked at previously
earlier I think it was in I want to say
December but this year we looked at this
game this year in one of my chest and
psychology classes and it was a very
nice strategical position on how to use
the pawn structure with black but it
wasn't against the double pawn it was
more against but we apply a lot of the
ideas because it's the same idea of
where the pieces go just this is even
slightly better because you have weaker
pawns that I can look for all right so I
like to play this c5 because my main
idea is to get my pieces out like this
d6 is not necessary so let me take it
off so my next five six movies to play
Casto be 696 Knight a5 Bishop e6 and so
that's what I'm trying to achieve so
white has different set up so I can try
to bring Knight to f3 and then try and
maybe defend with 92 but Knights coming
to e2 is more aggressive because it's
supporting the attack faster and when I
played this game I were I was aware of
these attacks with F 44 because I saw
some classic games which I will show you
after this game and I just wanted to
show you this game first so you could
get an idea of how dangerous it can get
in a real game well take the knight
experience and yeah so my opponent after
castle efore alright so my first
question for you what do you think white
ones and what do you think you should do
as black right now what's your next move
if you were white and if you were black
bollocks and it depends on the position
so right now there are no real good
squares in the center to try and have
your pieces there so and there is a
clear target so these are clear target
that's we are gonna try and use and
that's why the pieces are going to the
corners a little bit so
it should be seven maybe five yeah
burger and sear correct white one
special g52 pin and so you would play d6
buy black or h6 i I could understand
East six but I'm buddy six but I am
completely against h6 because fragrance
if you play h6 it's giving your
opponents clear targets to start the
pawn March like FY f4 f5 e 5 and that h6
plan is always gonna be super weak we
don't want to play d5 with white it
would be nice if white 485 because if
white were to play the 5 then you would
have this 95 this kind of whoops nope we
don't want that it's kind of pushing for
it I'm still not seeing to move that
okay so we have we have agreed that
white wants to play this correct so how
do we get rid of this pin let's see
this is possible but not not strongest
because the pin is is still coming
ninety-eight yes Tim I think you're the
first one to suggest 98 you're correct
98 is the best move why because he
simply wants to avoid getting under this
fire and you might have ideas with f5
yourself you might want to come to d6
and attack over here so these are going
to be your next few moves so playing t6
is interesting but you will completely
lose any chance of playing 96 and that's
why we don't want these six right away
so I guess - this game would be the
summary of most of the ideas that are
applied that could be applied in this
pawn structure and then after sync this
game we'll go and watch those ideas
separately like if white managed to get
this f4 5 attack how to stop that if not
with f5 and why is it important to play
this 98 so yeah I guess that's our today
plan all right
um kind of like Kings Indian ideas but
we are not really planning on attacking
in the kingside we were planning on
stopping White's attacking the Kings
side and attacking on the Queen side so
that for right now what do you want to
do as black I do know that Indian is
very strong last time I was looking he
he had crossed around the 2400 he wasn't
I am and he had crossed 2,400 I do
believe he he he either his what he's
like almost a GM or he got his Jam but
it's been a it's been a year since I
last checked so don't but yeah he he's
very strong and I'm glad I need him
so it's black to move remember this
these could become super dangerous with
push and push and one of the ideas to
get the night away was to have the idea
to stop at fives so what do you guys
think oh great he's a grandmaster 2500
quasi a all right 96 interesting g v g6
is still a little have I played growth
fold yeah I played few green felt I have
I had Austin positions but I didn't
actually get the results that I wanted
so I got a little bit discouraged I'm
still working my way back to Grunfeld
but let's see I'm still not seeing the
move oh thank you memento mori h f5 f5
is a strong because it blocks everything
if you take it now this is completely
blocked and I can come after your pawn
with the whoops with free head and peace
and knowing that my my position over
here is pretty safe so why should play
e5 now what do you play after e5 keep in
mind that this Knight is looking a
little weird over here and that you
ideally wants to be able to start
playing Knight a5 but are you gonna do
it now or is it a little too early
I put in abu-dhabi tourneys 2013 I think
I got my wim Norman 2013 terenia and 14
and I think I got a GG him on 15 or
almost something I think it was almost
won I had like a little performance less
than desired and in 2016 was the last
time I played I didn't play very well
2016 but I really liked playing there
all the time I like to go back what is
just so far because back then I used to
live in Iran and it was just like an
hour plane away
all right let's see what else we got
here so we're getting a lot of D 6 and D
6 and D fives ideas d66 should be the
right move and so the the main thing
that you should calculate with d6 is
what do you do after D 5 because D 5 is
like a scary one if take you're good you
just take with the night and
everything's fine and you're also taking
C 4 so the main thing that you should
calculate is what do you do after D 5
- quiet
so after d5 you want to play Knight to
a5 take over here maybe it's little not
scary everything good
well the way I wanted to go about it was
to take over here exchange and take this
because this would be such a nice pin
and this is not possible so that's what
I wanted to do but 95 is also quite
interesting because if you take over
here taking is kind of mandatory because
if not then we'll thank you for the pond
ponds and Danna after take if you take
over here this is the extremely strong
Bishop I could just even play Bishop
here and keep my Bishop or even this
should be four and now this Bishop is a
super monster this is also coming up so
you kind of do have to take it back with
the clean and after take over on e5
pretty cool huh
so why it's my opponents that in the
game was he played Bishop III now do you
think it's time to start with the knight
a 5s or they still want to prepare more
for its
yep 95 is is and so I think one of the
main questions to think about is what do
you want to do if Queen a4 because Queen
e4 is literally the only move that
actually is keeping this pond a little
safe but is it actually keeping it safe
what would you do with black
ninety-seven is very interesting so I
was thinking about d5 I'm not sure if
this is the move I would go for in the
game but just to brainstorm cuz you
can't take disguise pins but if you
can't take over here in c5 and then what
should I do it should take c4 maybe take
take with the night whoops and your
Bishop is kind of a weirdly placed but I
can't I just can't take it back just yet
so that's why I was thinking maybe since
so I will ideally I want to play d5 but
I can't because if d5 then c5 falls
correct so that's why I was thinking
maybe rook c8 and now I have two threats
why why they want to take over here and
then here or I want to play d5 on attack
here
Oh we'll be easy
well if you can't you can't just try and
say bring the rook next to the Queen and
I'll understand what you're trying to
say
yeah fragrance that's what I was
thinking
I thought about maybe Queen c8 - after
Queen a4 I kind of like the Queen here -
so that I still keep the d5 option open
and I'm still looking at this Bishop a
little so I don't think I would go with
Queen c8 but I would I think the move I
would go for is rook c8 because d5 is
giving my opponents too much chance to
open stuff up while here it's not as
much and also after d5 one thing that I
was thinking about well not that is if
you were to take here look this might
also be kind of interesting but I'm not
really sure how much I would enjoy this
because my bishop is is still pretty
weird over here and well it is it is a
nice position I can bring my knight this
bishop could be very nice but my
opponents is still has too much activity
so I think I would go with rook c8 yeah
okay so for all of the reasons mentioned
above he played the job of - now what
would you do would you take it
immediately or would you still try and
develop a little and then take it
um I don't like the idea d5 just yet
because the specificity this Bishop is
protected
if d5 you can take and I wanna I want to
eat that pun we love free puns so oh you
mean 97
well 97 is nice but what about the pond
this is free pond nobody likes free pond
sis well
so I didn't take the pawn I should have
but I was a little scared this position
why it's being able to pull something
off and I was like my knight isn't as
strong and I don't really know how to
open the position up so I didn't go for
it immediately like I mean I can't find
92 here but the check and I don't really
want that you get you get too much in
freedom as white but according to
engines this was actually better for
black just still complicated it's feels
complicated too so I was trying to
lessen the complication with Queen c7
and so Queen c7 my idea is super simple
I am still going for this guy and I
might be able to actually try and take
more stuff on the way as well maybe it's
considering say something like taking
over here maybe just keeping my options
open so what do you think these whites
should do
oh you want to start pushing g4 and
stuff huh
d5 yeah d5 should be the one of the
candidate knows that you guys are
thinking about good job easy easy six
should be too
I would love it if I played Queen b3 I
would just take that and tank my
opponents deeply
so my opponents play d5 which was
interesting now I would love it if you
guys gave me a line on up this candidate
moves on what should black do and what
are you thinking about do you see any
real tricks or threats stuff like that
because this is one of the high points
on the get in the game and like if you
make mistakes here then all of the
things you know about the pawn structure
and all the setup sets you've done it
would be kind of all for nothing so
triple pawns that would be cool but you
couldn't really force my opponents to
make bad news I wish I could
it is black to move in this position so
that's why I'm asking what do you want
to do do you want to take something do
you want to avoid stuff
okay I like the idea d5 and rook t8
that's pretty neat
I would it would be very very nice to
see a line like D takes e5 what should
whites to
okay so so taking on d5 I wouldn't do it
because I taking over here then I don't
really know what to do with this Bishop
I mean I could try to play C for and
push the bishop back a little
but even if c4 there's always this what
I was just taking my queen and then
moving the bishop back and everything is
kind of protective this is square is
super weak Knights can come Bishop can
come if Bishop c2 I could to consider
state taking but this is also opening
whites fish of a little too much on my
bishop and Knights are looking kind of
weird over here so I didn't wants to
give my opponent that chance by opening
it up that way so I took here I'm having
a suggestion from chestnuts on Knight
takes e4 my thanks e4 is interesting
[Music]
let's see what could be problematic now
we're taking over here could be
problematic but you might have d5 so
this is interesting if if with d5
let's see Knight takes e4 is there
anything worrying what about Queenie for
attacking this guy and this guy this
seems quite problematic
no nice e4 Queen a4
yep Thank You Josh
so Dee takes e5 for example you take
back I take back bishop g3 to activate
your pieces I don't really want to play
something like Queen f6 because first of
all this is very passive and second of
all why I why should I not give the
check and now so so far I took one pawn
with black do you think it's safe to try
and take this one or do you want to call
your blessings and start pushing pawns
maybe yeah so what do you want to do
okay so okay so if I was wrong
thank you because you lose your pond so
don't touch the e pond 85 seems to be
interesting I agree 85 seems to be quite
interesting one thing that I'm a little
looking at is what if I just give up on
this side and come take your ponds on
the other side because your pieces are
way into queenside so I could try in my
chance in the kingside that's why I'm
thinking maybe T taking on c4 is more
interesting and now what do you do after
Bishop c4 so officially on the board do
you have two more pawns but it's not
easy to actually like it's not like art
I'm super winning I can do whatever I
want so you have to be very careful so
and your queen looks a little misplaced
so maybe for white you could consider
something that has something to do with
the Queen and stuff because if you just
take it like that that's perfect
I'm good give me two more moves on us
start pushing these pawns like like baby
monsters so after Bishop c4 what do you
want to do is white keep thinking about
takes and the moves with threats and
maybe I'm trapping to clean and trying
stuff like that
baby monsters
this up for Oh be careful butts up if
you play like Michelle before this guy
is a little oopsy doopsy 9f for ya night
a foot ninth f4 seems to be the best one
rook F Street um I mean it's doable but
Queen just runs away so yeah Knight f4
so laughter Knights are for you are
protecting this guy and attacking this
guy and protecting this one so these are
kind of the high points on the game so
what do you want to do with black are
you gonna try and take over here take
over here try to free your queen
somewhere else push a lot of ideas huh
so it helps to think what why what does
white want white wants to take over here
white wants to attack your queen from
either here or here so white pants I'd
rather go after the cleaner after this
pawn so one of the first things that you
can start eliminating is a5 or 85 or
Bishop d5 so these three moves you can
immediately eliminate white is not
winning surprise surprise
there is a nice way for you to get your
Bishop out I gave it away there is a
nice move with the bishop to get your
queen out well the suggestion of Bishop
d3 I think my concern with the ship T 3
would be rook the rook e1 because then
the Queen can't really go anywhere you
could try like there should be two and
then like take over here maybe try to
get out but you have something stronger
yep enthusiastic enthusiastic you're
correct
Bishop b3 so the idea is quite simple if
it's white stupid style if you move
depending on where you move your queen
let's say you move your queen
well York Lincoln law it's only
logically go over here because if you
play like Queen Anne's five even though
my Queen seems to be a little trapped I
still have this D 2 square to go to so I
will just take over here and go to D 2
or take with the bishop and go to D 2 so
Mike in the game he plays Queen B 1 I
could have I mean I consider something
like C 4 and then if you attack me I'll
just go to C 5 but this is a little
unpleasant and unnecessary so you can
just take it over here and dear Queen
can just run away
so let's say overtake over here and you
take here so now you are two pawns up as
black so you do have advantage but how
can you actually convert this advantage
to a full point it is black to move try
and give me just few ideas on how you
want to get to your pieces back in the
game because your pieces are very
uncoordinated and okay the first move is
not that hard Knight f6 is actually
pretty easy to find because the threads
of Bishop h7 was coming so Knight to f6
okay we all can agree on that but after
that what do you want to do with this
guy what do you want to do with your
jokes just like a brief overview of what
do you want
okay so you want light to be on c4 and
probably your Akane eights or D sculpt
it so keep in mind that you're also
going you're attacking this guy as well
so let's say Queen c2 you play this
rookie this could be coming up so you
can't buy rookie 8/9 import is also
interesting I'm a big fan of mine c4 as
well matter Kate seems more legit at
least to me and now I get to have my
clone over here and in this position he
played Bishop d6 Bishop f4 is also
interesting but I always have this
finish 5s and I still save so my
question to you Bishop d6 what do you
want to do was black Jake Jake Jake Jake
cool ball
you're getting good
why would you resign black cos is still
pretty good almost winning think about
intermediate news all right Knight g4 is
interesting could you please give me a
line
great 94 Bishop g4 Queen d6 yeah so in
the game I played 94 but 94 is also very
interesting just because take you just
take it and if Bishop g4 you have Queen
d6 and if you don't take it and play
something like Queen e2 mmm I just have
ooh I don't want to give this up okay
let's think what would you do after
Queen e2 and I couldn't actually I
didn't find this move in the game and I
in the game I was like okay if not play
Knight g4 rooks get changed and then
clean e2 what am I gonna do next because
this guy is under attack this guy is
under attack
so nitrifiers not a blunder 94 is
winning think about intermediate moves
first of all this is not going to puppy
possible cause of coinage too so think
about a way to work with that idea
ruk f2 is interesting but what do you do
after Queen takes three four
9f2 is also interesting but still King
g1 and you don't really know what to do
with you look what are you gonna do to
keep six York f6 you can just take it
and meet coming up choose two bishops or
super-strong no 9 f3 is not the most
accurate one remember roof d8
interesting but after rook t8 so you
have the right idea to attack this
bishop but not the cannot the correct
piece hi Joseph
yeah Thank You Josh finally it takes
only 2,500 plus to find the moves right
yeah 94 94 it's the good one and so the
idea is that if you take over here well
great so I just take this and if you
take with the Queen 96 but my problem
was that if 96 Bishop d5 then what do I
do
this is a still super hard to actually
be able to win
so the move that I missed was after
Queen g4 there's Queen d2 and Queen d2
I'm attacking your whoops I'm whoops I'm
tagging a rook and your bishop and you
can't stop them and that was my mistake
so even the 51 yeah just take it it's
not like you can take it you get meat oh
well
Daniel if you said that sorry
yeah Queen d2 Queen d2 was interesting
and that's the move I missed in the game
Queen d2 just the didn't I didn't think
about it I'd like to think that I could
find it if I looked at it right now but
anyways I didn't play in 94 I played
mighty 4 and after 94 he took her rook
takes a feint because if Bishop takes f8
well there are a lot of tempting ideas
there is rook takes c6 and next I have
this there is if you take over here just
Queen take C 6 and your Bishop is a bit
trapped what else there is
maybe night maybe not tonight to g3 I
mean it's possible but I mean I think
this is also good enough and you take I
just taken I have this guy more so
Bishop my face doesn't work and that's
why rope takes up a trip takes effect
here here and ok now we have advantage
clear clear advantage cause we have
these to go whoops these two guys two
pawns against against the rope Hanna
bishop and the bishop is trapped so now
the main question is how to come take
the bishop
so how do you guys think you should come
eat the bishop
Queen f7 King g8 okay so sorry first of
all it's quite a move cuz it was blasted
with 93 and the rook falls so King G yet
a one I played King g8 so those of you
who said King g8 you're right and those
of you who said 93 if that was whitey
move that is also right and if it was
black to move whoa I keep getting my
whites and blacks mixed up today anyways
when f2 is pretty much the only move to
try and keep the Bishop because if I
take it yeah I let your rook get in and
your Bishop to go free and we do not
want to ask God maybe not specially
seven just 56 or Ruki eight anyway it's
just we don't wants you don't want to
give your opponent the chance to get in
the game so night if after Queens f2
Knight comes to c4 I'm completely
ignoring the fact that your queen is
over here and now I go for the Queen
exchange and now all right so this is a
winning endgame what do you want to do
how are you going to win
here you guys are good I should have
been more clear on whose move it is
nine top six very interesting be careful
Bishop e7 we don't want to get let the
bishop run away yeah
take the pawns take this guy first you
also have to the truth of this whoa whoa
and after group goes away you give the
check you get your night outs again
attacking the rook and now you come take
the bishop and the rest is easy-peasy
just make sure you're not losing your
pieces and he resigned was these are all
baby Queens all right Knight takes T
three very good yeah I gave you guys a
spoiler all right I'm gonna look at
prepare the next one so just let me know
if you guys are having any questions or
comments on this one so I have few of
the games ready one of them in
particular I think you will completely
love because it's our our Yasir so
that's one of the games all right let's
look at this one I did
thank you yeah it was a good game I have
some good games right Wow
six games alright so this is a game
that's been John teaming and the icer
cr1 you know you all know y'all sir
right if you don't know you're out there
you go right now
pause this video go on another YouTube
video if y'all start doing commentary
and watch those then come back and
re-watch the rest of this so I had a
question from Brian what if the foreign
exchange goes to g3 with the black hmm
okay tell them before we start this we
have a question whoops
from last one I'll be super quick before
I exchange our Queens so somewhere
around here
um
[Music]
what was the question if before wine
exchange goes to g3 and with the black
bishop
I don't know I don't get the question
sorry guys
Oh earlier
when the Queen was on d2o
the analysis this Oh your bow your fast
crush yeah
so if Bishop goes to g3 yeah you're good
Wow good job I don't I didn't catch
where you guys are talking about cool
all right
proud of you I'll crush all right let's
get back to you sirs game okay so in
this game with the hacer this was
actually a pretty nice game this is in
1983 so 15 years before I was born
and if you guys could see this cute
picture of us are up here that is really
awesome
she had this like seventies eighties
face yeah see up there it's pretty cool
huh okay okay so this was another
interesting name is only Indian and here
I like to play c5 but most I mean it's
kind of like similar ideas but after f3
it could become a little unpleasant and
that's why some some players prefer to
have its with b6 and in this one
particular was quite interesting because
f3 was played so the ideas actually does
that instead of playing III than efore
they want to go if or immediately and so
let's say you bring the knight house you
bring your Bishop out and this
unorthodox night a street so compared to
the other line when you would play III
and then you would bring your bishop
outs and your night out and then like
start pushing like this so the
difference is the night it goes on a
stream and actually the knight on h3
sometimes is actually more useful
because it's participating in the the
upcoming attack on the King and see
black hasn't had the chance to castle
yet and if Castle Bishop g5 is coming
you don't have the time to play 98 like
in the game that I played so yasser
played the night a5 and then cast oh and
he got this Bishop Jeep back that I was
trying to avoid in the in my game right
so Bishop g5 e 5 is coming right so you
kind of have to play d 6 e 5 what do you
do now
it's not very hard to move to play but
ideally instead of just the one mover I
want like I play like here my opponent
does that then I'll do this like just
like a to move calculation so weak I
could see that you are all following me
yep you kind of do have to play Queen d7
and the ideas if you take it I take it
and it's kind of safe for right now but
if you play Queen c2 I get a point 98
and that's what happened in the Oscars
game let's say Queen comes to e4 this
should be seven wind runs away a little
bit and now you do the up six because if
you don't go have sex first of all this
guy is coming and second of all your
position is really stuck and after
Bishop e7 you don't even have that hold
on c4 so you see how it can go bad so
fast have sex take you take with the
knight and now white gets to play Bishop
d3 now what do you want to play with
black because your position is getting a
little live too uncomfortable
so h6g sixties are doable but your
position doesn't need them right now
especially because well what is your
what is whites main threat if it's quite
to move again it was we're gonna take
over here will you just take with the
pawn and your queen is protecting your
h7 Ponton right so well funny fun fact
the AG instead of a six you can play
Bishop a six and go for this guy because
the thing is in this positions this idea
of on attacking c4 is one of your is
like your main idea so you should try
and work around that whenever possible
and so let's say Bishop takes you take
with the pawn and your queen is actually
protecting this so far safe and sound
castle
what do you wants to do now
Mackenzie that's funny sacrifices for
questionable compensation hi I was not
exist in compensation
well you can just take the pawn what's
wrong with taking the pawn that was your
whole idea to come take the pawn right
and after take take there's this knight
f4 and yeah sir played a five team on
took took with the Knights rickety one
coin up seven and they agreed on a draw
I mean the game still has a lot of
potential to be continues but I don't
think that just having that one pawn one
extra pawn wherever that pawn you want
to think it is it's going to actually
beat that difference mmm but it's not
it's not a decisive advantage so I
understand making a draw and I I will I
support it because the position why
definitely has compensation so it's just
a personal matter if he wants to
continue and take your chances or if you
feel like this position doesn't really
have much to offer I'm gonna wait a
minute on questions cuz I don't want to
keep going back and forth but as soon as
you have your questions blind
suggestions ready let me know
next we're gonna look at a game of
carlson versus Lecco 2007 it was a rapid
game so we can understand some of them
but I just like to share the idea on how
they play this
no questions
well I'm glad you guys are learning
all right everyone ready for Carlson
well okay so why not can you say Church
it it is possible I'm not saying that
the position is a dead draw I'm saying
that the position is dangerous and white
has definite compensation so if you feel
uncomfortable playing in a position that
you're your king is open your opponent
is more active pieces compensation and
you're just all you have is one more
pond and it better supposedly better
pawn structure with no clear advantage
it is it is a it's there's nothing wrong
with you accepting a draw offering a
draw that's what I'm trying to say
okay so let's get the Karlsson ready
you better be with these Claussen
tonight all right
so this cam let's look at it from whites
perspective cuz counseling is white and
we all want to be Carlsen okay saya saya
crush yeah and I would be cool feel free
to send it away I am working on the
Queen versus York end games okay
the to answer the question for be easy I
don't see why the Bishop captures Bishop
in both games okay so the thing is if he
were to take night if you were sick
Knight takes e4 the problem is that your
bishop on e6 is always gonna be pinned
with that bishop on d3 so that's the
main reason you kind of just take it
with the with the with the bishop so you
don't have that pin all right so let's
get to crossing game alright so this is
a cross on game it's mean that's
happened in 2007 it was a rapid
blindfold game and he played it against
Peter Lake oh all right so this is a day
started with a tree and continued with F
tree like in the game between teaming
and Yasser immediately for immediate
Bishop g5 not even playing Knight
extreme and here the Lego played the
idea with long cast Oh someone suggests
that that last in the last game and so
black simply trying to play long castle
and I'm not I'm not saying that you
should play long castle I'm just saying
that's an idea too that you can consider
and if that's your style sure go work on
it and that's doable so I'm just showing
you what is doable and what are some of
the ideas in it so let's say after a
long castle let's think what should
whites do first of all what do you want
to do with your King I think that's the
main question what do you want to do
with your King
SIA crush how do I send it that's a good
question i don'ts my life I'm not sure
let me think about that a little I'll
let you know
I'd like to the tile style well meet you
we would all like to have a super tall
style don't leave and sacrifice
everything and whoa
[Music]
so you think shorts Castille well you
put jobs try to keep the king in the
center there's no attacks direct attack
on its right now so okay we have some
answers and what to do with the king now
my other question for you is what movie
you want to play right now as white
so you want to close the center and put
the king in the center interest and
close the yeah
so I have ideas at c5 on Queen a4 I feel
like c5 is coming up but not just yet
maybe another move or two
yes Magnus is white yeah great great
Gunther d5 so my idea was not my idea
but Magnus's idea is well if you take it
whoops if you take it take attack the
whoops attack the knight and attack the
bishop you take it over here I can just
take it with the King and what do you
want to do with your knight and deke
White King is already getting a little
bit safer well when blacks King is
already getting a slightly weaker so
that is that is the idea and after d5
Knight a5 what do you want to do now
surprisingly Magnus didn't win this game
think about so this book was actually
suggested last move and queen a4
possible but something more aggressive
also keep in mind this was a rapid game
and blindfold yeah c5 the idea is quite
simple you take it over here now are you
gonna take back or are you gonna come up
with an intermediate
yeah good job d6 so yes you can take
back and take him back as nice too but
d6 is a whole a whole different level
d6 take take Queen us to go to f8 King
takes F 1 this King's looks so exposed
and e5 might be coming up like if you
play Knight p7 I will definitely play
something like II 598 he 5 now how can
black try to dig himself out of this
hole
once next few move could be just to try
and bring the knight in if black plays
like super chill and doesn't really do
anything
so like needs to up his game black needs
to go a little chop-chop fast yep
nap six why is never gonna take this
just because Clint can take nice can
take T six and blacks position has the
potential to become explosive very fast
and so after f6 you know you're not
gonna take it
so with white what do you want to do
yes yep windy tree if king b79 you
cleric be one you might want to come
have ideas like that let's say f takes
e5 what do you do now
hey Chi 5 is also interesting but right
now the game is more in the center and
Queen side so that's why everything is
happening over here and it's better to
try and just play over there so right
now what do you want to do with white
how do you want to get your pieces out
how do you want to try and you know
maybe sacrifice something
yeah um okay clingy for check is good
knight c6 now and the game Magnus took
on b6 I can't say I would do the same I
wish I I wish I knew I would do it and
he just went about its like that and
here what should whites do you see why
don't ask this to material that he is
trying to attack with and the like it
seemed like what definitely needs more
pieces so how can you try to achieve
that can you actually try to get your
other pieces there
well think about movie threats
so one of these rules the threats could
be Rick v6 and the idea is quite simple
I'm going for this night you will the
night it's made so what should black do
yeah good job on finding your p6
everyone
yep Burke p8 take now g4 now black is
the one attacking cuz black has more
pieces to go for this King and eyeglass
King looks super weird and weak but it's
still holding on Queen D 3 so that's
what p1 can't happen
so Ruby 2 happens going after this is
square 92 blocking it's now g3 see how
strong this is again mates coming up so
what should Magnus do
I mean all of these moves are possible
okay if it's blacks and move its mates
so it's wise to move all of these checks
and checks are possible but if you move
your queen so let's say if you give this
check this and the next move Queen f2
bye bye see you next game so you have to
be very precise
okay so think about it like this this is
becoming mates right so just run away
with the King yep
good job Akshay finding King you want
what if roofie AIDS now
now this guy's coming
good job everyone finding king b1 he was
a strong move now
find another strong move please
well Carlson resigning whoa you're
kidding me that's never gonna happen so
in the game he plays kang ji-hwan and
the idea is pretty simple you give me
check I'm gonna block you let go to
Queen III this one check over here and
now what do you want to do is white
kingi one thing the one was pretty
strong even even though this was a rapid
game and this position looks super
sketchy and everything
no no enough enough King moves let's
think about some pawn grabbing maybe I'm
in the game we did take Knights here 95
Quincy six-man then they just repeat it
because after an IP five in this
position after 95 what can you do this
might see trees coming and that's
actually pretty nasty and Queen is
forgetting fork to take my king and
everything so and after night a seven
what can you do take over here I mean
you don't really want that's right so
all you can do is your Queen should be
in this diagonal so that's route p1 is
avoided and nice p5 is not letting you
stay in the diagonal so that's how the
game ended in a draw now I want to show
you another game while you guys are
thinking and maybe give me a few
questions on what you think on this one
just give me a second to prep it cuz I'm
actually gonna mix bunch of games
together so I can show you better and
hopefully it's not gonna be confusing if
it's confusing we can always go back to
the way I was showing it I just need to
waiting anyone questions on the last one
because we can't always go back no
nothing
cool I'm still finishing up this parts
whoops if my mouse doesn't keep jumping
a little up and down control
did it
all right I am ready to show you this
game from what's Winnick and another
game from this f3 line okay so now let's
see if I have any questions for the last
one why can't black take the pawn on c3
with the night
Barnes let's see why not
okay so I'm ready to go for the next
game but because I have a question
we're gonna take a look at the Magnus
game why can't I see six half and I see
three happened well 93 can happen but
I'm assuming something like king c2 or
king D 2 and what do you want to do next
check I just go up and eventually you're
gonna run out of tricks and this truck
is gonna become very active if you try
to create more checks so I'm assuming
that the king on d3 is actually kind of
safe so yeah alright everyone good for
next one who
okay so now I'm gonna try to summarize
the stuff that we've seen while showing
apart when it came and so this game this
is like I kind of combines a bunch of
games together so I could show it better
and when we get to the game I can share
the game the the name of that specific
players that we're looking at and
hopefully there won't be any confusion
if there are just let me know and we'll
clear it up okay so this is a typical
nimzo-indian setup here we have a White
House bunch of moons there's a 3 there
is Bishop g5
there's g3 there's Knight f3 there's III
there's Queen c2 and those are just Oh
f3 those are just a few those are just
like the main ones they're a bunch of
others too so for Queen c2 I explained
this idea with knight c6 and one of my
earlier videos and we have a link in the
description below so make sure that if
you want to check that out
so far we've been focusing on a tree
with III and f3 and those are actually
pretty nice to have around because if a
tree taketake knight c6 or c5 earlier
your choice and let's say knight c6
there's f3
there is III and so those are the things
that we are going to watch so the game
that Yasir played was with f3 and in the
asters game that I believe it was a
knight a stream or yeah it was a knight
h3 one that's he also did this Knight a5
and Queen and then he did Castle there
are lines with Quincy aides
and it's doable but I don't really have
any strong feelings like for or against
it the Queen c8 who would be to try and
delay the Castellon Gong either sides
and to get away from the beam Bishop g7
Bishop g5 ideas so that's something to
look at if he wants to now instead of
night a street what if a five earlier so
II five my g8 93 you gotta move the
night point a four so this was a game
done by oh god help me with
pronunciation Diaz column art versus
real De Aza hopefully we can get that in
typing maybe and it doesn't it doesn't
eat both of them are 2,400 players and
so they Bellini 7 and after C 5 and
bunch of exchange this actually turned
out pretty well for black but what I
looked at and I liked instead of Queenie
7 was 97 and so my idea is if well it's
not my idea it's like my preferred idea
is if you play something like 95 I'm
just gonna play Queen c8 put my Queen on
b7 and just hold this position like that
and this is actually this position that
I'm showing you this line is a game
between Jo guava versus pie ruling in
2011 you all know Java the crazy tactic
I've just sacrificing everything has
supercool line so he's from Georgia
higher drooling is a Russian Grand
Master and yeah so
it's just I'm just showing you quickly
on what's date it and it's actually nice
to give it a try if you want
Quincy it's kind of weird but that's one
of those ideas that if you're thinking
about is in the game you're most likely
not going to do it but if you know it
beforehand you can try to it oh I've
seen this before so I could try to apply
that so that was the idea with 95 I'm
gonna show it quickly on Bishop d3 again
you can do the Quincy 8 idea and pretty
doable right so one thing that you don't
want is you don't want to do short
Castille in these positions that's like
a death sentence already 95 coming f4 f5
coming Bishop g5 it's like everything
don't not do that and right now I
realize that I sounded like Caleb didn't
be a little when I was doing like this
is coming that is coming
that's anyways okay so that's the line
that I wanted to share with you the
queen c8 queen b7 queen c6 idea now
let's get to about spinach game because
that's also super cool game so your
pawns can't start with a 3 and then
transpose it to e3 f3 or can't start at
e3 and then get to f3 and a lot of
different transpositions but it's just
good to have these ideas alright that's
the last thing you start at e3 I do my
c5 and you would get this double pawn
nice comes out I get my cast Oh
one thing to keep in mind is try to
delay d6 as much as possible I didn't in
a game that I played against a
grandmaster in 2017 and the game ended
kind of painfully and yeah just try not
to do d6 too fast cuz you also might
want to bring this night in whoops
you might want to bring this night over
here so don't do d6 too fast but
you do do your Castille and get this
that side ready to go now
all right now I remembered so if if we
remember correctly in the previous in
the game that I played there was some
stuff that there were like the f4 lines
and my opponent played Castille and then
f4 that's I played f5 so I knew that f4
f5 idea because of the game that I'm
about to show you that part Winnick
played as black so what is Bishop e3
this shall be 3d6 this is what between
each plate d6 is right now necessary
because if not if you play over here you
would lose the de-spawn and you kind of
want to keep your pawns ideally so d6
cancel you bring out the night bring out
your Bishop now so this is a good
position for white white managers manage
to have a decent setup for the King side
and center and the Queen didn't go into
weird positions and the Queen is
defending the bishop so the I don't
really have those d5 ideas anymore so as
black what do you want to do
yeah it's true a lot of these closed
semi closed positions our idea rather
than line memorization but you do have
to know that if your opponent is playing
e4 the ideas Bishop g5 so you see e4 you
position has to be ready to run away
with the night so you got to play this
98 ideally all right yeah I got a
recommendation for Queen d7 you are
playing very well so here both Winnick
is white but when it played f4 and after
f4 now we get to f5 this is why I knew
this because of this but when it came
but I think is white but I call it but
when it came so this is a very this is
very interesting because you can try to
play you could try to play f6 but the
problem is if you were to play up six
it's possible there is so many you so
cool from carpals games in it and again
it's doable
but you have to be careful like you're
kind of ready if you get f5 you're gonna
go E 5 if you get a 5 you're gonna go F
5 and I prefer to have my pawn on f5
because of the personal experiences but
it is perfectly fine to play f6 as well
so it's a personal choice do you like f5
go for it you like f6 conference but f4
f5
so well why it's not gonna take this
right because then the tension is gone
and all the focus is gonna be not all
the game and the focus is gonna be on
this guy
there could be your seeds coming taking
this guy is like just sitting duck so
why to a jerk you on and now my question
for you as black is what do you want to
do now
okay so I'm getting ideas with Queen on
a form and she tries to bring out the
nice but lineup sticks is a blunder so
Knight f6 not really my top choice
because Knight f6 you can just whoops
bye-bye pawn but you do have to write
the idea to bring out the night so
that's why g6 you want to bring out the
night and your Knights gonna stay here
happy hold all of these pawns and just
wipes greats right everything is
protected and you can go after this pawn
and voila
so after g6 what white can do well white
can't really do much because the attack
is kind of stopped so white can try to
positionally make some changes like 51
maybe coming for a 5 maybe d5 just to
have ideas after rook t1 those of you
who have been watching my other videos
and streams know that I hate it when the
rook is against my queen and I always
run away so just having said that what
do you want to do now
pz is asking it bishop a 695 required
for today's lesson well kinda yeah
that's the whole team that's the theme
theme theme there we go yeah working on
my pronunciations every day so yeah
that's the whole theme of today because
I was coming I have been showing you
these pawn structures and I have been
showing you how to play against it and
the whole idea is to have that if
they're if these two pawn pawns are here
the double pond
this is one way that you can play it
with the bishop and the night and then
we saw the ideas with Dylan d6 having at
98 F for immediately a 5 or X 6 and that
Queen C 8 Queen d7 ideas so yeah we have
been doing these what is most important
when you're trying to improve improve
the position or your level because for
both of them the calculations you need
good calculation because if you can't
calculate even if you have a super deep
understanding you're gonna get caught in
calculations these Knights Isaac's never
play to keep this C file free for the
rook um I mean you already played this
knight c6 and then a 5 so yeah you want
to play with c8 eventually all right so
black point something like queen of 7
and the idea is simple I am running away
and now I might start looking at I'm
also kind of looking at your pawn over
here and my queen is keeping my King
saved so Queen Elsa is a positional it's
positionally great
all right so after Queen f7 e 5 what do
you want to do as black
well 97 okay so the problem to answer
chuk chuk hope is night the 97 the
problem is that where you gonna go next
everywhere is blocks for you so but if
tonight doesn't g7 97 even though
doesn't really have a better place to go
is keeping the king safe and warm
all right so I'm having the fiber I'm
getting D five suggestions but hold on
if even if it's quite timid what's not
gonna take this right because then your
knight gets to come in so that's why I
took c8 is the better move through CAS
if you take it oh thank you
I brought whoa frozen chess place flying
Knights full
still frozen chat space a little bit
yeah all right well everybody we are
having a lovely fur frozen chest bass
how is your day going
it's not that hard to get it back though
and I know which game is one so I'll
just go back to that game as soon as I
find it there we go
and control one for Ben Simon ctrl F for
me and we were somewhere around here
yeah huh thank you thank you less than
30 seconds of fixing all right school so
Brucie 8 and I was telling you that
taking taking it doesn't really work and
that's where the 9th row so I'm a little
scared to touch this land right now but
step the problem was that's well that
guy is super weak and my night just got
got my night just got a job pretty much
where as nice on ei didn't really have
anything to do so that's why white won't
take this instead white white rook e1
again white is just but what winning is
just sitting there waiting for the
opponent's to you know make some moves
make a mistake maybe maybe not okay
so
after rookie one taking over here taking
with the D well the thing is if you take
with F the problem is that this guy now
has three attacker and only two defender
so we can just take it and take the pawn
C delicious right so that's why the
white has to take back with the D so
there is no more activating the C a jerk
now now black managed to finally get
this Knight to g7 cuz let's be realistic
this Knights never gonna actually see
the light of day even he could come to
c7 where you go next there's like all of
your squares are kind of blocked so
might as well stay here protects ee6
protects the King and everything's good
right laughs happy ninth one now you get
sixty eight so one thing to be cautious
this light is not completely useless
because the knight can go over here and
have some ideas over here these two guys
are still living even don't it's not
like in the center or in an outpost or
anything everything is is still going
and in a rhythm so Bishop f2 9 times 5
I'm attacking your pawn bishop g3 and
this Bishop is also pretty useless right
I mean if this Bishop goes here are
rights yeah that's a monster Bishop but
that's never gonna happen
so now how do we bring more attack on c4
pawn
doubling Gandhi file is good that's
something that's coming up soon but you
have a better better move better idea
yeah Queenie 8th Queen a for Congrats
NIC and Anna and whoever else were
thinking about it's yeah cleaning AIDS
queen a4 now these guys are all pushing
on here and why it's simply breaking a
little also this might be coming up and
all of these puns are becoming Gonzo's
so Queen a2 seems to be the only move to
actually protect a tree now remember how
you guys hated this night when it was on
eh right now the 9th 157 h5 and takes
the bishop now I'm gonna ask another
question what do you want to do with
black so black has a better position see
all of these pieces are actually doing
something useful and you just have to be
able to create more threats on more
attacks so this is why the guys are
thinking about a move I'm gonna suggest
I'm gonna keep talking and giving some
advice so I've heard this expression so
many times and in this specific position
that's something that's they're useful
so growing up and I was learning more
about strategy
everybody kept telling me that's okay
you can't win a game with just one
weakness
you need more weaknesses like you need
to have you can't just keep attacking on
c4 because your opponents will keep
defending on c4 applies to this position
and that's why black needs to create
another weakness so now my question is
how do you do that b5 no roof takes d3
oh please don't you your position is
good you don't need to do sacrifices
even if it might work you would be
giving your opponent too much chance
so this book might be a little weird so
I'm just gonna say it and then for the
future moves we can it should give you
better ideas age five it's a very
beautiful game so the idea is to try and
get this truck maybe to age eight maybe
and try to push on h4 depending on what
white does so if Y is just sitting like
this for five move I'm gonna play like
king of seven bring this guy and voila
so after h5 why spice Queen e2 Bishop e2
King up King up and now in this position
each one wants work as well anymore cuz
there's always Rakesh ones and that's
why we when we go for Queen exchange now
the the main thing is that this endgame
is better for black because White's
completely stuck white cannot improve
this position and the some of you might
ask well how is black going to improve
it I'm gonna show you Bishop d3 bring
the King closer go back keep the
pressure now try and double your rooks
up now the problem is if these guys also
get doubled the death threat Oh actually
Colin I want you guys to find this cuz
it's kind of pretty
well there are some there different
threats and ideas so doesn't necessarily
have to be this one but one of it that I
was just thinking about was trying to
play Knight d3
let's say the main problem is that black
white is in zoos long if you move the
king now this is this is pent C now I
can take if you don't move the King you
just go back a little this is still the
bishop is kind of weak right 93 what do
you do this guy falls so the biggest
problem is the concept that White's it
is wrong he move the knight this happens
whoops you've the pawn I can just move
my King a little bits and it was nice
knowing you
yeah so you see that's the biggest
problem white is in zoos long and that's
why that is why white instead of
pointing octave whoa instead of priority
one white try to play g4 to create
something so I can take maybe Roku's
maybe something can happen who knows and
if you take with this one
Bishop g6 maybe trying to get something
out of it even though g4 is not like a
serious stretch it's good because it's
creating chances for white so after g4 I
wouldn't take it
just because I'm giving my opponent too
many chances but you also have to find
accurate move which is route d7 now the
only movie to actually do have to
consider is these takes or take which is
the same exact position and after take
take Brooke has to come to d1 right
because if you're if not 61 then well
what do you do
you move the bishop rookies bye-bye
you don't move the bishop
well the bishop has pins now this is
coming right so very very interesting
position so Reshevsky managed to force
this zooms wangan Botvinnik not h4
completely paralyzing over here
now remember how we talked about this
King e1 earlier that was impossible
because of Knights p3 well if nothing
possible but that but well here King III
same idea after King a 193 here these
are the last few moves but this is
already super winning well not super
winning but winning enough for a
grandmaster buzz Phoenix tried to pull
some stuff off with maybe a check over
here
and the most precise move is to take on
D to the chef ski did that and to try
and exchange more pieces off and that is
what two chefs get it so here you just
have to be precise enough not to let
your opponent just make clean which is
like five moves away so pretty much all
you have to do is put your king on e6
try to go to f5 and keep everything
under wrap or if we're capturing 43 and
this is a winning position as well so
yeah
that was a beautiful game beautiful
endgame and I I really wanted to share
this whole concept of the news of Indian
with those two double column video
because I was thinking about some more
more practical and more just idea based
openings rather than just the
so funny enough today earlier on our
twitch channel we did Meraki on ladies
night class with Thalia so if you want
to go learn about Moroso you can do that
too I'm considering doing more stuff
like this just combining and talking
about ideas and more of my chess and
psychology classes and any of the the
classes that I teach so if you guys like
this let me know and I'll keep working
on creating like series like that and
picking some games of mine and some
others and doing it like this well I
hope you enjoyed it keep pressuring your
opponents in your daily online games and
keep let's keep pressuring throughout
this whole quarantine and well it will
be nice at the end hopefully alright
have a good night and see you tomorrow
[Music]
you